la première règle de la diplomatie est que la
vérité n'est pas une question de fait est un autre
consensus
Je veux faire une
différence le gars qui dirige les choses
là-bas, il n'est pas orthodoxe, ne le
sous-estimez jamais d'accord, vous avez
quelques minutes Michael
Justin cutter intelligence centrale Je
ne vais pas bien vous repérer, gardez vos
yeux et vos oreilles
comme ça  le centre de l'univers
toutes les grandes agences de renseignement sont ici
tout le monde essaie de troquer leurs
secrets et leurs informations de services
écoutez bonsoir nous admirons beaucoup
le travail que vous faites pour le
peuple irakien vous n'avez pas à me remercier d'avoir
fait la bonne chose  nous vous laissons à
votre paisible soirée
n'oubliez pas votre enveloppe
c'est un homme très dangereux un jeune
diplomate rien ne se passe sans lui très
dangereux pour vous d'être ici sur son
port  rait profiter de regarder Moscou Pékin
Saddam a des fonds mafieux il y a une liste
qui contient des noms de personnes qui sont
toutes payées par des subtils nous
parlons de personnes haut placées ils
prennent des millions de dollars en pots-de-vin
plus de frais impliqués chacun sont suspects
ont déjà une vidéo  de vous me prenez pour
- lui j'ai reçu un appel je pensais que vous alliez tous à la
CIA mi5 Interpol Dieu a un gros pour moi
mais elle veut que vous fassiez oui
[Musique]
vous m'avez demandé de risquer ma carrière
vous devez  Croyez-moi,
tout a fondé votre temps
lentement,
pas de mauvais garçon, bien joué avec
vous